elle n'avait jamais connu ça en quarante
ans de métier
deux mois et demi de fermeture depuis le
18 mars imposée pour des raisons
sanitaires et les annonces faites jeudi
par le chef de l'état ne la rassure pas
on aurait pu se dire on a déjà fermé
quatre semaines ont prouvé déjà pas ça
juste en plus sans reprendre une couche
de semaine et demie après la fatwa
revoir comment ça s'organise mais on
récupère pas au dernier confinement n'a
pas récupéré alors la semaine dernière
elle a vu rouge
la commerçante a voulu alerter
l'exécutif par un geste peu banal c'est
destiné à jeter ce texte envoyé des
chaussures usées au premier ministre
alors j'ai fait un petit courrier pour
l'accompagner où il ya marqué c'est une
paire de chaussures n est essentielle
je vous invite à porter celle-ci si vous
êtes intéressés vous pouvez commander en
aquitaine collecte en suivant de la page
facebook alors j'allais envoyer la
semaine dernière lundi dernier dans le
but de leur faire prendre conscience que
les chaussures c'est essentiel et que ce
n'est pas nos naissances y connaît en
l'air de le dire puisque si nous n'avons
pas dans la rue personne ne marche pieds
nus
aucun autre personne marcher pieds nus
le but c'est ça et leur dire il faut
nous laisser rouvrir puisque nous
travaillons comme je vous le disais à
l'ancienne et que nous nous sommes
vraiment des gens qui sont qu'ils ont
très attention on est très responsables
quand même avec 400 m² de stock plein à
craquer soit plus de cinq mille paires
la commerçante ne sait plus orange et
ses chaussures et surtout comment les
vendre mon bilan sartre ont besoin donc
sur les deux premiers mois de l'année
passée donc donc avril 2020 vous êtes
perdu 18%
sachant que demain c'est mon quarantième
shatter nous affecterait la 41e année de
chaussures c'est la première année où
sur baisse
on a ri chaudronnier quand même et pour
lui pas du tout commerçant donc il
comprend pas me disant si tu en as tu en
as est plus facile
après ça devrait faire le tour de la
bête pour marc la taille pour contrer
ces fermetures de commerces non
essentiels des initiatives sont prises
pour limiter les pertes
les clients nos clients à les ont
achetés 10 euros qui ont été contents en
fait sachant qu'ils pouvaient payer -
une grande majorité s'est démarqué en
faisant le click and collect pour pour
certains du portage à domicile et tout
le monde ça moi tous les commerçants qui
font partie de notre association et même
les autres on vrai font vraiment le
maximum quand vous attendez que pour les
non essentiels dit non essentiels ce
sera le 19 mai mais pourquoi ils
visionnaient quoi pour l'heure agnès n'a
pas reçu de réponse de la part de jean
castex elle n'en attend pas et bien que
la date de réouverture ne lui
conviennent pas elle se console en se
disant qu à pithiviers au moins personne
ne marchera pieds nus grâce à son stock
de chaussures